[Música]
tuvo lugar en brasil el primer debate
presidencial un cara a cara inicial
entre ella y bolsonaro y luiz inácio
lula da silva hubo menos tensión de la
esperada entre ambos candidatos que
prefirieron hablar de los logros de sus
respectivos gobiernos
la vice presidenta argentina cristina
fernández está en el centro del debate
público tras el pedido de 12 años de
condena por supuesta corrupción para
muchos de sus seguidores es una figura
idolatrada a la altura de grandes
nombres del progresismo argentino
analizamos
todo está listo en cabo cañaveral para
el lanzamiento este lunes de la misión
artemis 1 la nasa espera con ella llevar
de nuevo al hombre a la luna luego de 50
años esta será la primera de las tres
fases de la misión espacial
[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 si rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto acompañarlos abrimos este
informativo dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano en
brasil en donde tuvo lugar el primer
debate de la polarizada campaña
electoral para las elecciones generales
del 2 de octubre la esperada tensión
entre el ex presidente luiz inácio lula
da silva el actual mandatario ya ir
bolsonaro se resumió a un solo k'ara
k'ara directo ambos prefirieron resaltar
los logros de sus respectivos gobiernos
nuestra corresponsal en río de janeiro
valeria sacones nos amplia ha sido un
debate tibio en que se ha hablado poco
del futuro de brasil y ha habido muchos
ataques personales el primero al
principio del debate cuando ya el bolsón
aro acusaba a lula de ser el presidente
más corrupto de brasil por el cazo
petrobras y le llamaba en dos ocasiones
de expresó lula se defendía recordando
que según él bolsonaro estaría
destruyendo el país y criticando su
gestión de la pandemia de el coronavirus
una guerra de versiones de narrativas en
el que cada uno de ellos ha citado sus
logros presentes y pasados con la
diferencia de que lula ha estado de
perfil bajo según su equipo porque está
intentando conquistar el voto de los
indecisos mientras que bolsonaro ha
perdido la línea en dos ocasiones y ha
atacado a dos mujeres una periodista y
una candidata la gran revelación de la
noche ha sido simonet m ch y la senadora
que ha liderado la comisión
parlamentaria que investigaba la gestión
de la pandemia y ha habido varias
ausencias en este debate no se ha
hablado de violencia en un país donde el
año pasado murieron de forma violenta
más de 41.000 personas tampoco se ha
hablado de racismo en un país donde el
77% de las víctimas de homicidios son
negros y el tema de lbg que fue tan
importante en las elecciones de 2018 ha
desaparecido por completo del mapa uno
de los temas que ha tomado especial
relevancia en la campaña electoral es la
cuestión religiosa mientras lula dasilva
defienden la laicidad el estado
bolsonaro ha vuelto a recibir el apoyo
mayoritario de los evangelistas un grupo
cada vez más influyente álvaro cordero
no es amplia
brasil vive una campaña presidencial
especialmente tensa y en esa disputa
entre ella y el bolsonaro y luís inácio
lula da silva la religión ha tomado un
papel protagonista la politización de la
fe da muchos votos en brasil y detrás de
ello está uno de los grupos más
influyentes del país los evangelistas
cristianos protestantes de carácter
ultraconservador que son fundamentales
para bolsonaro
él es un presidente que está con
nosotros que habla en el nombre de dios
que habla en el nombre de jesucristo
el presidente brasileño lo sabe y por
eso ha hecho suyas muchas de las
reclamaciones de este colectivo como la
oposición al aborto la defensa de un
estado confesional o la reivindicación
de la llamada familia tradicional
brasil es un país destinado a triunfar
y destinado a ser cristiano
un país destinado a ser libre
y la fuerza llega a cada uno de ustedes
el crecimiento del poder de este grupo
es espectacular en los últimos años
controlan desde televisiones hasta
pequeñas asociaciones vecinales y su
influencia va desde multimillonarios a
personas en la más absoluta pobreza
incluso han llegado a captar votantes
tradicionales del partido de los
trabajadores de lula da silva algo que
supone una amenaza para el ex presidente
las tumbas
luis ignacio lula da silva defiende un
estado laico el estado no debe
patrocinar la religión
todas las religiones deben ser
defendidas por el estado de vista
pero también tengo que decir que las
iglesias no necesitan un partido
político y las iglesias deben
preocuparse de la cuidad
el futuro de brasil dependerá en gran
parte de la fuerza que pueda tomar en
las urnas este colectivo al que un
tercio de los brasileños pertenecen
nos vamos hasta argentina en donde sigue
la polémica en torno al pedido de 12
años de condena a la vicepresidenta y ex
presidenta cristina fernández por
supuestas irregularidades en la
adjudicación de obras públicas ayer
sábado hubo incidentes entre la policía
y los manifestantes que se juntaron en
torno al domicilio de la expresidenta
para mostrarles su apoyo anteriormente
pudimos hablar con alejandro frenkel
doctor en ciencias sociales por la
universidad de buenos aires quien
analizó que representa cristina
fernández para sus seguidores
no solo es una de las figuras más
importante del gobierno es un gobierno
que podríamos calificar una suerte de
coalición sino que además la oposición
también se estructura en función de un
fuerte antikirchnerismo
y en ese marco además cristina es una
figura muy popular en términos de una
lideresa carismática con una gran
cantidad de seguidores que diría que muy
pocos o casi ningún otro dirigente
tienen argentina
con esa capacidad de movilizar miles de
personas
alejandro frank él también nos explicó
como su éxito se ve asociado a otras
importantes figuras del progresismo
argentino como las de su difunto marido
néstor kirchner y eva perón
que el propio periodismo es un
movimiento que tiene una tradición
que se ordena en función de fuertes
liderazgos y carismáticos
y vamos en ese sentido eva perón junto
con ese momento juan perón fueron parte
de los que inauguraron esta tradición y
néstor kirchner junto con otras figuras
en otros momentos la historia han sido
también líderes del peronismo y figuras
que han sabido
transformarse en líderes populares
entonces en ese sentido cristina es
parte de esa tradición que tiene el
periodismo como un movimiento popular de
masas
organizado general alrededor de fuertes
liderazgos en cabo cañaveral en florida
y hasta todo listo para el lanzamiento
de la prueba de la misión artemis 1 un
proyecto dividido en tres fases
en tres fases que pretende devolver al
hombre a la luna por primera vez en 50
años y próximamente construir una
estación espacial este lunes se tiene
previsto completar la primera de las
tres fases de la misión veamos más en el
siguiente informe
miles de personas están acudiendo a cabo
cañaveral para tener la oportunidad de
presenciar este lunes el despegue del
vuelo de prueba no tripulado de la
versión artemisa
esta será la primera de una serie de
lanzamientos que espera llevar a
astronautas a la luna por primera vez
desde 1972
desde el transbordador espacial
realmente no ha habido nada tan
importante y volver a la luna qué
emocionante es eso no puedo esperar ya
para tener una misión tripulada a la
luna de agua artemis también quiere
desbloquear otro hito pretende poner a
la primera mujer de la primera persona
afro en la superficie lunar el objetivo
final de la misión afirma la nasa es el
próximo salto gigante la exploración
humana de marte nos gustaría realizar
misiones humanas en la superficie de la
luna y alrededor de ella seguidas de
misiones a marte usando un enfoque de
acumulación gradual nos gustaría
demostrar tecnologías y operaciones para
vivir y trabajar en una superficie
planetaria que no sea la tierra
la misión inaugural de este lunes ver a
despegar hacia el espacio a un cohete de
98 metros en lugar de humanos habrá
maniquíes de alta tecnología llenos de
sensores y solamente orbitarán la luna
antes de volver a la tierra el alunizaje
real está programado para 2025 durante
la tercera entrega de la misión pero
algunos expertos señalan que mis tres
podrían no tener lugar hasta 2026
spacex la compañía espacial del
multimillonario y lomos construirá el
módulo de aterrizaje para artemis 3
después de que su empresa fuera elegida
sobre blue origin propiedad de jeff
bezos
cerramos este informativo en colombia en
donde miles de músicos se juntaron en el
parque simón bolívar de la capital
bogotá para ofrecer el mayor concierto
del mundo en torno a 16.000 personas de
diferentes orquestas filarmónicas y
escuelas de bogotá tocaron al mismo
tiempo un total de 6 obras musicales
para celebrar el informe final de la
comisión de la verdad sobre el conflicto
armado en colombia
con estas imágenes nos despedimos les
invitamos a que sigan conectados a
france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]